good evening as it was said by the Pope
recently well I hope that the binary
people will not be upset if I start with
an homage to the sterling library it was
there that I I got the first idea of the
library I imagined for my novel the name
of the Rose it happened when I was
exploring one of the mezzanine which you
could not reach by the elevator and were
pretty somber and funeral so that at a
certain moment I felt lost unable to
find a way out
and in that moment I had the vivid
impression that if I have killed
somebody put in the corpse somewhere
under the shelves it took a lot of time
before it was discovered and that's it
with such a peaceful and gentle picture
in my mind I started designing my own
library as a labyrinth keeping in mind
that according to a medieval definition
don't tip each lobule in Tuesda note
that Allah that is a labyrinth is a
model for the world but if an aberrant
is an image of our world a library is an
aberrant then by a transitive property a
library is an image model and then our
thoughts of our world but since our
world as such as we know it is the one
depicted by our culture that
ellaby renting library is the equivalent
of our culture in so far as cultural in
the anthropological sense of this term
is a system of ideas data values habits
and traditions that all the members of a
given group are sharing so that it
existed a great culture of the age of
Pericles as well as it exists a bond to
culture
if you run the delivery through a
library you can be people by steal an
ingot multitude of bookish equals of
your previous cultural experience become
Isaac and Isaac begat Jacob and Jacob
because the man all a bunch and that was
when I saw the pendulum on the branch of
kama late were latest with birth saying
there's knows of yesterday softly
falling into the dark mutants
Shannon waves mysteries and leisure
mystery cushioned upon a time by any
other name is out of joint the women
come and go a kiss is just a kiss and
their roses roses are all to kwok-wai
alia a man without quality shouldn't ask
what he can do for his country beauty's
true through this beauty too many rings
around Rose because happy families are
all alike see love is iike master : go
world the lemon blossoms once upon a
time the earth was without form leashed
mara lyft uber alles count as well -
what is life names names names
brilliance of Brahma wind of Robert
Israeli Jurassic Park Madame de
Pompadour Smith Smith & Wesson roselucia
book clear optics Matthew Mark Luke John
P na Christine ty is the hole with the
shitty fingernails
osteoporosis Antinori back a putana
principal Isabella Alexander's ragtime
and the Gordian knot that is all you
know on earth and all we need to know
once once tomas pavel colleague of mine
invited us to try a fascinating mental
experiment let's suppose that an
omniscient being is capable of writing
or reading a magnum opus that contains
all the true assertions regarding both
the real world and all possible worlds
naturally since we speak of the universe
use in different languages and since
each language defines the world in a
different way there exists a maximal
collection or the total image of magna
opera
let's now suppose that God churches a
number of angels with writing daily
books for each individual human being in
which they take note of all the
propositions concerning the possible
worlds of that individuals desires and
hopes and the real world of his acts
that correspond to a true statement one
of the books that make up the maximal
collection of magna opera the collection
of daily books belonging to a given
individual must be produced on the day
of judgment along with the collection of
the book concerning family tribes and
nations but the benevolent Angell's who
write a daily book are not content to
align the true statements they connect
them evaluate them and build them into a
system and since one this is on the day
of judgment individual and groups will
each have a defending Angela the
defenders will rewrite for each
individual and other gastronomical
series of daily books in which the same
statements will be linked together in a
different way and differently compared
to the formation of some of the Magna
opera since infinite alternative worlds
make up each of the infinite Magna Opera
the Angels will write an infinite number
of daily books in which affirmation that
are true in one world falls in the order
and they will be mingled together if we
further hypothesize that some of the
angels may be clumsy and
sapa for mation registered as mutually
contradictory by a single magnum opus
what we will end up with will be a
series of compendium miss LAN is
compatible fragment of miss LAN is that
amalgamates straight as books of
different origins and at that point it
will be very difficult to say which
books are truthful and which fictional
and with respect to what the original we
will have an astronomical infinity of
books each of which we straddle
different worlds and we will no doubt
consider us true stories that others
have considered as fictional this gives
us a good idea of what a maximal
encyclopedia might look like if we
substitute for the angels or the human
beings who left behind their traces from
the Bisons about a mirror to the
invention of writing and beyond the
legend paavana race gives a reasonable
representation of our situation when
when confronted by the universe of
affirmation that we are accustomed to
accept not as true but in any case as
once expressed he is the picture
provided by pavol an image of the
culture we live in happily not because
confronted with the virtual immensity of
the maximal encyclopedia which is a
regulatory hypothesis we usually attempt
to reduce its format to construct local
representation with the purpose of
understanding a single context this
means that the culture is not only way
for storing our memories but also a way
to filter them
speaking of the meaning of a given term
we usually refer to a standard set of
notions on the basis of which both a
layperson and the naturalist can agree
on the properties evoke by the term
Mouse both understand it in the same way
the sentence there is a mouse in the
kitchen but for the same word Mouse
there is also a specialized knowledge
shared only by natural ists so on the
one hand there is a standard
encyclopedia shared in the present case
by both by the naturalist the common
native speaker and all the order and a
managed and manageable unmanageable
plethora or specialized encyclopedias
the complete collection which would
constitute the unattainable maximum
maximal encyclopedia which pavel was
speaking accordingly we could imagine
the states of strata or what Hilary
Putnam has called the social division of
linguistic labour by thinking of a kind
of solar system the maximal encyclopedia
which a great many specialized
encyclopedias describe orbits of various
conferences around the central nucleus
the standard encyclopedia so it could
happen that the works of Plato except
for the time years were not part of the
standard encyclopedia of medieval
culture while it is still part of our
current Western encyclopedia the idea
that the Ptolemaic system was believed
to be true in the past whereas it is
today considered erroneous
without his being forgotten to sum up we
might say that the official standard
encyclopedia of our present Western
culture
is represented by the 32 volumes of the
Britannica why the single members of our
culture share only part of it according
to the format of the education they
received so that a mid cultivated person
master more or less a mid-sized one
volume of general information
it happens with the format was
encyclopedic an encyclopedic information
what happens with the difference between
the number of words mastered by a newly
newly emigrated taxi driver and the
university professor besides once I met
him Florence an official of a Washington
agency who why tasting a delicious fish
from the Italian coast asked world the
Mediterranean was a salt or fresh water
lake I obviously answered that it was
sold
Addington in fact it was bigger than
Philadelphia in fact even though all the
content of a starter encyclopedia are
not shared by all the members of a given
culture a cultivated person may have a
forgotten or never hand have known but
the date of Napoleon death but knows
where that information is accessible an
educated person is not someone who knows
the days of the beginning in the end of
the Seven Years War but someone who can
come up with them in a short time the
started encyclopedia cannot be
identified with an extensive library
containing thousands even millions of
volumes because such a library though it
may not be may not be commensurate with
the maximum maximal encyclopedia
nevertheless encompasses the started
encyclopedias of exotic cultures of past
civilization and ideally all of the
specialized encyclopedia
the past imprisoned said that the
Sterling is such a kind of encyclopedia
the Beinecke is instead a patchwork of
specialized encyclopedias of different
ages and cultures the fact that not just
the maximal encyclopedia but even the
parody of it represented by a normal
library should provoke the vertigo of a
knowledge so exaggeratedly extensive
that nobody could ever capture or
contain in their own individual memories
leads us to the problem of memory and
forgetfulness the problem in other words
of the vertical of the labyrinth since
classical antiquity the problem of the
need to forget appears contemporaneously
with the development of many monic
techniques by which to commit to memory
the maximum amount of information
especially in the centrioles in which
information was not as readily
obtainable and transportable as it
happened with the invasion of printing
and subsequently of electronic device
so a scholar had to go around with
techniques able to make him to remember
to remember the encyclopedia he had not
in his hands the classical example to
which you can find here in the Milan
collection of name of techniques is
based on the construction on the
imaginary construction and some time on
the design the construction of a complex
spatial image a palace square a city
were there architectural items or
statues many representing strange or
terrifying facts to which one could
associate every kind of data concepts
logical principles events and so
so that by figuring out of visiting the
place and remembering these images one
could remember a complete system of
notions sometimes was more difficult to
remember the many monic images than the
data to be retrieved and one of the
terrors of the practitioners of
mnemonics what that was that remember is
so much as to confound as a result
result today ideas and forget
practically everything it seems in fact
that at a certain point in his life
Giulio Camillo who constructed a big
theater of memory maybe you have read
about it in the books of Francis yes
Giulio Camillo had to excuse himself for
his confused state and for the gaps in
his memory citing as an explanation is
protracted and frantic application to
his theaters of memory on the other hand
in this Parliament against arts of
memory cornelius agrippa in the vanity
edition theorem claimed the mind is
rendered obtuse by those mocked by those
monstrous images and by being so
overburden is led to madness
hence parallel to the fortunes of the
artist's memory the reference from time
to time of the fant
fantasy of it hearth oblivion alleys and
art of forgetting in the oratory for
example Cicero sighs the case of
Themistocles who was gifted with an
extraordinary memory when someone
offered to teach him an ass memoranda a
memo technique Themistocles replied that
his interlocutor would be doing him a
great kindness if he taught him how to
forget what he wished to forget then if
he
Oh team how to remember in as much as he
would prefer to be able to forget
something he didn't wish to remember
than to remember everything he had once
heard or seen so in the lesson 20 of his
pluto's of young Philip possess Waldo
1592 reviewed many methods for oblivion
just Waldo is aware that you harness
pandabear use in his libelous
artificially Molly reminded his readers
that people forget from corruption that
is from forgetfulness of past species by
diminution all the agencies and from
ablation of cerebral organs likewise it
is obvious that we can forget by
drunkenness and drugs but that was not
the problem of Philip urges Waldo his
intent was to develop an art of
forgetting that employed the same
techniques of an art of remembering and
so I advise quote first having recited
and wishing to consign the images to
obligin either in the daytime with
closed eyes or at night in darkness
you should go wandering with your mind
through all the imagined place evoking
an obscure nocturnal gloom that highs on
the place and proceeding in this fashion
hasn't going back a number of times with
the mind and not seeing any image image
everything you will soon disappear go
peering in all the place with Demand
back and forth and contemplate them
empty embarr as they were formed for the
first time without any images in them
and this operation should be performed
several times just as the painter passed
us over and whitewashes his paintings to
cancel them so we too can cancel the
images with coral paint and over them
and these colors are white green or
black imagining over the place white
curtains green sheets of black cloths
and going over the place of a number of
times with these bales of colos and one
can also imagine the place stuffed with
straw a firewood merchandise etc I
consider an excellent route to put in a
place new figures because just a one
nail drives out and order so forming new
images and putting them in the place
already imagined cancelled the first
images from our memory it is true that
it is necessary to imprint them with
great care a mental effort and to repeat
them frequently in the darkness and in
the quiet of the night so that the
intense and vivid idea of the single
second ones drives out the first ideas
or imagine a great storm winds hail dust
ruined the buildings and place and
temples a flood then leaves everything
in a state of confusion and when this
knocking thought has continued for a
while and being repeated several times
finally go walk in it one of the places
with your mind imagining the weather
bright and calm and peaceful and seeing
the place empty and bare as they were
formed for the first time and imagine a
man with hostile terrible and fearsome
with which troupe of armored companions
enter and passes impetuously among the
places and with scourges tapes and other
weapons drives how the likenesses as
Souls the people shutters the images
posed to fly through doors and windows
all the animals and animate the persons
who were in place until after the tumult
the tumult has passed and the ruin
seeing the place with a mind recovered
from its terror they will be seen bear
and
I confess before and if this destruction
were to occur on the hands of hostile
armies such as the Turks and pagans it
would be even more effective because
that terror confound things and sets
everything upside down that there are
the rules for forgetting try try this
night at home and see and see what
happens we don't know whether anyone
ever put into practice the artifice just
world or recommended but we are entitled
to suspect all the stratagems made it
possible
made it possible not to forget but to
remember better what he wanted to forget
and to remember it with greater
intensity as it occurs when lovers tried
to blot out the image of the person who
has abandoned them
and the more they canceled the ball the
countenance of the beloved vividly
resurfaced and I think is a common
experience their psychological and
physiological reasons why an ass
oblivion alleys is impossible depends on
the continuity similarity dialectic on
which the classical mnemonic systems are
founded even an object X has been
imagined to be in contact with an object
Y or if an object X means is in some way
homologous or similar with the object Y
every time the object Y is a booked so
is the object Y but if this is how the
surface memory work it is hard to see
how well how one can imagine an object X
that when evoke somehow acts on our
cerebral cortex by canceling why
how them to forget undesirable
information while we already encountered
the problem in the mr. place through
Cicero the dread of excess certainly
increases with the invention of printing
which not only makes available in
enormous quantity of textual material
but also facilitates access to it for
the man in the street then leads from
the primacy primacy of remembrance to
the primacy of forgetting
thus we witnessed the development of an
art not unknown in the centuries of
manuscript culture by which acquires
central importance in the culture of
print d as extended that is the art of
compiling abstracts of summaries as to
retain only the knowledge we judged as
indispensable and to let marginal
information fall by the wayside in any
case what we may call the mystic less
complex returns over and over again in
the course of the cultural history and
one of its most dramatic manifestations
is surely the second of Nietzsche
untimely meditations which this with the
advantages and disadvantages of
historical studies for life and
Nietzsche wrote about quote the capacity
to sense the things and historically the
person who cannot set himself down on
the crest of the moment forgetting
everything from the past who is not
capable of standing on a single point
like goddess of victory without
dizziness of fear will never know what
happiness
is even worse he will never do anything
to make other people happy imagine the
most extreme example a person who did
not possess the power of forgetting at
all who would be condemned to see every
were coming into being such a person no
longer believes in his own own being no
longer believes in himself sees
everything moving points flowing out of
each other and loses himself in his
dream of becoming he will like the true
pupil of Heraclitus finally hardly there
anymore to lift this finger forgetting
belongs to all action just a boat light
and darkness belong in the life of all
organic things a person who wanted to
feel utterly and only historically would
be like someone who was forced to
abstain from sleep
right the Beast that is to continue his
life only from rumination to constantly
repeated rumination for this reason if
it is possible to live almost almost
without remembering it is generally
completely impossible to live without
forgetting Oh to explain more clearly
concerning my thesis there is a degree
of insomnia of rumination of the stoical
sense through which living comes to harm
and finally is destroyed whether it is a
person or people or a culture and of the
Nietzschean
quote this is for nature in his
meditation the starting point for an
analysis of the negative effects of the
excess of historical studies which
disturbs and reached such an unbearable
complexity and richness to oppress the
memory of the culture and now comes the
call for youth to develop and out of
forgetfulness you know one of the
interesting things about this text is
dead
while these remarks seem to address the
individual's need for survival
the emphasis changes to the need for a
systematic forgetting on the part of a
culture in general this switch is of
capital importance because once the
impossibility of voluntary forgetting
was individual more what the individual
memory has recorded had been
demonstrated then cultures present
themselves as a system that function not
only to preserve and handle information
useful to their survival but also to
also to cancel the information judged to
be in excess the culture is surely a
device for storing and preserving a
collective memory a system of data and
values and when all these treasury of
information is lost that culture
collapses and disappears but the culture
is at the same time a device for
limiting and access of information the
culture has historical memory is not
only a stack of data it's also the
result of the percolation it represents
our ability in throwing away everything
we do not consider useful or necessary
the history of a civilization is made up
with millions of data which have been
buried frequently we have discord that
such a process was lost and we needed
centuries to retrieve lost information
our Greek ancestors have forgotten the
Egyptian mathematics and the Middle Ages
had forgotten great part of the Greek
science likewise we have by now
forgotten the meaning of the staff
of the Easter Island and many of the
tragedies quoted by Aristotle in his
poetics are definitely lost however in
spite of these undesirable accidents a
culture must eliminate a lot of
information by the way this process of
cancellation not only holds four
cultures but also for our personal life
Haga luis borges who certainly had read
the pages of Nietzsche
he was just quoting wrote as you
probably know a beautiful story fullness
and memory also on a cart fullness given
a fullness who remembers everything he
every live is so in his childhood every
word he heard in the course of his life
every murmur windy felt on his skin
every sentence he read just because of
such total memory fullness was an idiot
paralyzed inability to filter and to
throw away the result of his experiences
our unconscious works because it removes
if then something disturbs us we asked
our psychoanalyst to retrieve what we
removed because it was too embarrassing
but it was important to eliminate all
the rest and our soul is the product of
such a selective memory if we had the
fullness memory we would be animals
without soul that is without identity
our identity is made not only by what we
remember but also by what we succeeded
in forgetting however a cultural
frequently doesn't only make individuals
forget what they know or knew it also
keeps them from it also keeps from them
finding out what they do not know yet
saintly and a half after Nietzsche's
take
reflection cultural forgetting has
intensified and without renewing the
provocation of Nietzsche's cry of alarm
the process of cancellation continuously
performed by a culture simply in order
to stay alive alive today appears normal
identify memory and culture today we
started forgetting that the culture
mobilizes to various kinds of
cancellation which can range from
sensual the erasure of manuscripts
bonfires of books
damnatio memoriae forgery of documents
documentary sources negationism until
the forgetfulness out of shame inertia
remorse down to those processes current
in exit science in which it is decided
not only the hypothesis proven erroneous
but even the efforts and procedures
followed to arrive at the correct ones
are expunged from the specialized
encyclopedia of the particular science
because it is believed that they are no
longer useful which provokes terrifying
holes in the scientific biographies such
a loss of memory is disastrous for a
culture but today if not in the
humanities at least in her science
things go this way and in many
scientific essays you can't find by blah
graphical data older than 10 years as I
was saying yesterday this happens even
the humanities once I found the
philosophical texts suggesting that the
given idea was already present in kant
and the footnote read C Brown 1998 if
the specialized encyclopedias are
subject to the process of forgetting so
much more
so is the standard
Pina of a given culture it guarantees
remembrance of the important historical
facts of the principles of physics but
it omits an infinite amount of
information that the collectivity has
repressed because it decided it was not
useful nor pertinent our standard
encyclopedia provides pressures that a
details about the progress of the Battle
of Vitello but it doesn't give us the
names of all the participants including
obviously the fifty thousand casualties
he tells us all we need to know about
the death of Julius Caesar but nothing
about what is Widow Calpurnia did after
the assassination of his husband her
husband this is not a case of male
chauvinism because the same encyclopedia
records everything that happened to
Clara Schumann after the death of Robert
see his Clara continual continued her
career as a distinguished pianist and
presumably had the torture the love
affair with Brahms it simply means that
the fate of the poor Calpurnia was not
relevant for the history of our
civilization as well as the fact that at
Vitello a given Jean DuPont dead instead
of a John Smith it was useful to forget
this data so as not to overload the
collective memory more than we can bear
and without rendering the filter and the
censored facts irretrievable since there
do exist
specialize in individuals let's say
historians archaeologists capable of
bringing them bringing them to light in
such cases the collective memory
sometimes picks up on the data restoring
them to the standard encyclopedia
and sometimes decide instead to leave
them in some specialized engine
reservations the filtering performed by
the startin encyclopedia doesn't depend
on the wheel of an individual or on a
conscious act of collective will it
occurs out of a kind of inertia
sometimes if I from nature cause like
the cancellation of precise information
regarding Atlantis if it never existed
the problem of filtering by a start an
encyclopedia was in any case already
present among the medieval and secret
encyclopaedists even though they seem to
us to be intent on handing on everything
that tradition has entered onto them in
the labellum apologetic ohm that serves
as an introduction to his speculum Myers
Vincent of Beauvais is already shocked
by the proliferation of knowledge this
is why the sides to make his
encyclopedia a floral ahjumma
you know there was a selection of the
best of his readings not to be suspected
of censorship
Vincent calls the so called decretum
give us the arnhem the libras recipe end
is at noon recipe and this a compendium
of what was either apocryphal or
canonical in the Holy Scripture and
Vincent decide to quote also forbidden
books so that his readers could make a
distinction between true and false texts
and decide what to trust and what to
forget but in this sense certain texts
survived only because Vincent included
them in his speculum mail - even though
isn't it included them as wrong text all
the culture does then is to select the
data for his
own memory it may not do what Stalin did
when he erased from historical
photographs the face of the comrades he
had sent to death what they always Big
Brother did when he corrected the news
in The Times every morning but when we
read it that some English school
proposed to abolish the tinge the
teaching of the cruiser is not as so as
not offend the sensibilities of the
Muslim students it becomes apparent that
culture is a continual process of
rewriting and selecting information what
distinguish distinguishes a big library
like barricade from that of a high
school or from the personal one of an
educated but not specialized the person
I said that if we read Aristotle's
Poetics we find the mention of many
tragedies which have not survived until
our times we do not know why these
tragedies got lost as well as the names
of the authors in a Eve a policy is that
Sophocles Aeschylus and Euripides
survival because they were the best ones
the best ones according to which
criteria by which inscrutable reasons
they were selected in dental and academ
may be marvelous loss tragedies were
sensual maybe by corruption and bribery
an athenian athenian authority or that
Sophocles was performed more frequently
that some of its unfortunate the
companions how to repair to those
unpleasant accidents cultures at least
our Western culture philologically
oriented cultures are concerned with the
possibility to retrieve data data whose
loss we consider
disgrace that is why we need have work
of specialists supposed to resurrect
notions and experience by which by
accident sank in the dark in doing this
the collective memory is able to reimage
this data and puts them again in the
started encyclopedia on some specialized
one it is why a major cultural decides
to put some information in a latin sea
state exceeding information is a Wars so
to speak
deeply frozen so that when it is
necessary experts can put them in an
ideal microwave oven to retrieve it
again for instance in order to decipher
an old document a newly discovered the
Latin see places represented by the
modern oval library or their archive as
the indispensable containers of a wisdom
that can be revisited even though it was
not revisited for centuries nature is
there are cases of very very deep
latency in the sense that something had
been really forgotten and ignored for
centuries and no library was able to
store and that's and that sometimes is
rediscovered by chance
like the Reata bronzes which since
centuries were buried in the deep sea or
the Dead Sea Scrolls or the NAG Hammadi
manuscripts in this case the culture
must revive rewrite its files and then
reach either its specialized
encyclopedias or the standard one or
both
no Encyclopedia no library keep notes of
all the soldiers who took part in the
water law battle on the contrary we have
the complete list of the 1000 Garibaldi
need that went to Garibaldi - - to
conquer
sylia we have ordinay but they were they
were less that the Feist
the fighters at battle oh let now
suppose that scholar succeed him pot in
his hands as yet and no archive and
finds these names I do not know how
useful can be to have all those names
but we can then move this data from an
inaccessible maximum encyclopedia and
insert them into a hyper specialized one
and perhaps that least could be hosted
by the Stirling library or if written on
an on a nineteen century manuscript by
the by the key one to which encyclopedia
belong the texts of the lost tragedy
tragedies mentioned by Aristotle until
now
specialized literary encyclopedia can
simply record that the datum that of
these texts we know only the titles what
will happen if these texts will never be
retrieved for the very fact that there
are good reasons to believe that they
once existed every starter was not a
damned liar we will keep going on
thinking that they could belong to the
maximal encyclopedia the one described
by Pavel with his history of engines
even though belong to it only virtually
and in an objective way thus the maximal
encyclopedia if the term only lets us to
think of something who use need my use
coach Atari posted something on which
nothing greater can be thought of like
the god of Anselm of Canterbury is a
structure virtually according like which
can one day or another be stretched in
infinitum which is not a little
encouragement
for the Advancement of learning and the
Permenter hope for a great library ready
to embrace in its uterus even the wind's
dumb the wisdom of tomorrow thank you
meaning
thank you much thank you very much
humberto echo for that fabulous fabulous
talk it will keep me thinking about my
own job of forgetting and remembering
for a long time to come
I forgot to mention at the beginning
that we have a reception to follow at
the binary library so please come and
join us for a chance to follow up on
this wonderful talk and to to enjoy some
refreshments with with Umberto Eco and
uberta by Lascaux that do a Umberto